تتجه الازمه السياسيه في النيجر شيئا
فشيئا نحو اختبار للقوه لا يمنح لاي من
طرفي الصراع طرف الاختيار فالمجموعه
الاقتصاديه لدول غرب افريقيا اكواس تجد
نفسها في مازق لا يقل حرجا عما تواجهه
قياده الانقلاب في النيجر اكواس تضع على
الطاوله امرين اثنين اما حل متفاوض عليه
يعيد الحكم الدستوري ويمكن الرئيس المحتجز
محمد بازون من ممارسه صلاحياته رئيسا والا
فالتدخل العسكري سيتكفل بهذه المهمه
وهذا باب في حراسه الديمقراطيه بالسلاح
متجاوز لمفهوم السياده الوطنيه ومصادر
للتعبيرات الدارجه عن حق الدول في التعاطي
مع ما تعتبره شانا داخليا
نريده للوضع الدستوري ان يعود باسرع وقت
ممكن بالنسبه الينا وفي نقاشاتنا هذه هي
الماده الوحيده على جدول الاعمال والا فان
تهديدنا باستخدام العمل العسكري ما زال
موجودا على الطاوله اما قاده ما يسمى
بالمجلس الوطني لحمايه الوطن فهم ايضا
ليسوا اقل تصميما من اكواس في المضي على
ما عزموا عليه مؤكدين ان لا عوده لبازوم
الى السلطه بل قالوا انهم ربما قدموه
لمحاكمه بتهم ترقى الى الخيانه
فالمجلس بقياده الجنرال عبد الرحمن تياني
شكل حكومته وهو يانس الى شارع مؤيد له
ومعارضه تقف معه لكنه ترك بابا مواربا اذا
رغبت اقواس ان تدخل من وهو العوده الى
النظام الديمقراطي بعد فتره انتقال تمتد
الى ثلاث سنوات ولا يتاخر مسؤول اكواس في
رفض المقترح نثريه
الفتره الانتقاليه غير مقبوله بالنسبه
لاكواس ولا ندخلها في مقايضات مع
الانقلابيين موقفنا واضح يجب ان يطلق سراح
الرئيس بازوم وان يفرج عن عائلته وزملائه
في الحكومه وان استعاد النظام الدستوري
رغم ما اعترى اجماعها من نقصان برفض مالي
وبوركينا فاسو وغينيا لمقترح التدخل
العسكري قد حسمت امر التدخل بمقرره قاده
اركان الجيوش احد عشر بلدا من جمله خمسه
عشر من انفاذ قرار التدخل الذي حددوا اجله
دون الافصاح عنه
مالي وبوركينا فاسو اخذت قضيه الحرب ماخذ
الجد فارسلت طائرات مقاتله الى النيجر
دعما لها وربما دفعا لشر تتحسبان له من
تلقاء اكواس والدول الثلاث بهذه الوضعيه
في مواجهه اكواس تدخل جميعها تجربه لا
تعلم عواقبها الا بمقدار علم الناس في
النيجر وفي افريقيا عامه بمقدار حظ
الديمقراطيه وحظ المصالح في مشهد النيجر
الشديد التعقيد
اكوارس المصممه على قطع الطريق على
الانقلابيين واعاده الرئيس المحتجز بازومي
للسلطه تجد في فرنسا والمانيا ودول
الاتحاد الاوروبي بعامه ظهيرا مؤيدا
وداعما ومشجعا كل ذلك بدا جليل في لقاء
وزيره الخارجيه الالمانيه
بنظيرتها السنغاليه ولا شاغل الا النيجر
وديمقراطيتها
الوضع معقد هناك فالانقلاب في النيجر اثر
على خطتنا للانسحاب من هذه المنطقه ندين
هذا الانقلاب الاتحاد الاوروبي يدعم ويرحب
بجهود اكواس لاحلال الديمقراطيه في
المنطقه ومن اجل دعم جهود اكواس علقنا
الاموال التي كنا نقدمها للنيجر ونعمل مع
المنظمه ضد الانقلابيين انها الديمقراطيه
ولا شيء اخر
لكنما لا يقال لا يخفى ثم تم مشاعر كارهه
لفرنسا في كل من النيجر ومالي وبوركينا
فاسو وثمت اقبال على دول اخرى بحثا عن
شروط نهوض بلا اكراهات وهل الدول الاخرى
غير روسيا والصين الدولتان اللتان لا
تنغصان على حاكم بحديث عن ديمقراطيه او
حقوق انسان هنا مقبن الازمه الافريقيه ليس
في النيجر وحدها وهنا ايضا معضله
الديمقراطيه التي يحمل عليها الناس حمله
بالتجريدات العسكريه
الديمقراطيه الحقه يصنعها اهلها ويحمونها
كذلك حين تدعو الحاجه اكواس ومن هم وراءها
يقولون بل بالسلاح تفرض